mounir déjà comment tu vas toi
aujourd'hui comment tu te sens ça va
mieux ramiro leurs invités ça va ajouter
beaucoup mieux néanmoins il faut pas
croire que ma santé rétabli à 100%
mentez pas rétabli à 100% non parce
qu'on parle souvent on parle souvent des
effets secondaires du vaccin mais on
parle pas des effets secondaires du duc
au vide qui est très grave
je vais pas parler de mes propres
souffrances parce que elles ne sont
propres et qu'elles sont terribles je
pense que vous pouvez apporter mes
avocats que vous voulez ou bien des
citoyens engagés un peu comme olivier et
tout ça mais là la vraie vérité et se
trouve à l'hôpital
elle se trouve du fait qu'ils aient pas
de place ni combien de temps à l'hôpital
dont je vais vous expliquer en trois
temps moi je suis resté 48 heures aux
urgences parce qu'ils n'avaient pas de
place où j'avais une saturation à 82
d'accord lorsque je suis resté 48 heures
aux urgences parce qu'elle n'est pas de
lit qui avait pas de passants
l'animation on m'a dit de retourner chez
moi alors que j'étais dans un état pas
terrible lorsque je suis rentré chez moi
ma saturation tombe à 80 2 c'est à dire
que j'avais énormément de mal à respirer
et je commençais à suffoquer on appelle
le samu sommes sur paris capitale encore
mal ça va être comme new york lors ce
qu'on appelle un samu ça arrive
visiblement le mec nous disait monsieur
nous n'avons pas de sa bulle
vous devez attendre quatre heures pour
qui est ce que je vous conseille dit
avant de faire de vous prendre de
griller le feu rouge elle avait tout de
suite à l'hôpital lorsque j'arrive à
l'hôpital effectivement j'étais encore
six heures parce qu'il n'ya pas de place
la vérité alors avec tout le respect que
j'ai pour vous olivier elle n'est pas
sur vos fiches parce que si vous êtes
engagés nous et pas besoin de chiche
pour les lire moi je vous parle les gens
qui sont sur le terrain qui souffrent
d'accord et ya par contre une chose qui
nous rejoint tous les deux et peut-être
des millions de parents aujourd'hui vous
avez des enfants j'en ai aussi des
petits ma plus grande à 6 ans lorsqu on
va les faire vacciner effectivement on
est toujours un peu anxieux donc les
vaccins qui sont obligatoires et aussi
les vaccins qu'on nous conseille de
prendre pour nos enfants mais non dit
non parce que justement on connaît pas
les répercussions qui peut l'avoir moi
et ça il s'avère que il ya un vaccin
qu'on a refusé pour ma fille et
lorsqu'on est parti dans un voyage ont
le plus activement à dubaï elle est
tombée gravement malade parce qu'on
n'avait pas fait ce vaccin
aujourd'hui c'est quoi la réalité
c'est à dire que je m'en fous ma d
antibes accéder font ce qu'ils veulent
ils ont droit passe ils n'ont pas envie
de se faire vacciner qu'ils se fassent
vacciner
mais qui applaudissent et les médecins
et les infirmières à la première vague
est ce que faisait partie des gens qui
ne les applaudissait oui ou non oui
comment ça se fait qu'aujourd'hui les
gens qui les applaudissent aujourd'hui
disent nous on veut pas qu'ils aillent
désengorger un petit peu les hôpitaux
publics pour ceux qui n'ont pas les
moyens d'aller dans le privé
parce que les couloirs sont pleins t'as
rien compris j'ai rien compris alors je
tends pas rien compris et
nous on a compris
venant d'un misogyne franchement ça
m'embête un misogyne quand même on sait
si si on
s'intéresse aux ti cats c'est ce que je
veux c'est envie de prendre des fiches
prend des fichiers c'était juste que ce
que j'aurais encore maintenant en fait
le problème tu laboures maintenant mais
je dis qu'est ce que je veux avec cette
chose au liban merci dire que je dois
faire on n'est pas sur la télé réalité
on est chez cyril hanouna non mais c'est
super attention à sa table c'était on
connaît leurs noms mais je vais te dire
le vrai problème où il est oui monsieur
mépris des milliers ben hilal au mépris
et le mépris qui sait qu'il a eue en
arrivant c'est lui ou c'est moi qui me
choque
il est un gentil beau gentil
mais le vrai probléme c'est parce que
t'as pas dû regarder t'as pas dû
d'instruire en fait 8 milliards
22 répondent même pas instruire ses
pattes gilliard 69 mille lits fermés en
15 ans dans 69 mellifères maire jean 800
millions d'euros pendant la crise
sanitaire pendant que l'état en train de
nous expliquer à nous aux français qui
sont là pour notre santé 800 millions
d'euros d'enlever 69 mille lits si on
n'avait pas fermé celi t'aurais pas tant
due aux urgences et des drames
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est pas de la pole de mounir dans
les six jeunes hippolyte les bâtards
vaincu en train d'innover de l'afutt en
fait des autres mais
les gens qui va nous sauver l'hôpital
c'est parce qu'il a dit boehner s'est
passé parce qu'il a dit ce qu'est une
guerre monnières mondiaux en tout cas en
tant que personnage tu ferais un
excellent quand les actualités jean
semaine
si tu veux on peut à venir j'en ai plein
j'ai plein de trucs que j'ai été voir
c'est pas beau
mais en plus c'est un million et demi
qui regardaient ce que j'en sache alors
y'a un truc l'attachante en fabrique de
mines richmont dire je parle je parle
juste du principe que aujourd'hui
c'est aberrant de savoir que aujourd'hui
un peu plus de 40 millions qui sont
vaccinés et qu'un à d'autres encore qui
fonda rébellion ils ont droit de faire
la rébellion juste qui respecte de
mettre au niveau des passes sanitaire
qui maintenant en danger les autres et
pour en revenir au galop jeune homme qui
est qui étaient là tout à l'heure c'est
olivier disait je pense que c'est pas
bien donc entre pensée sur que c'est pas
bien c'est deux choses différentes moi
j'ai quelqu'un que je connais qui a fait
un faux pas de sa maison j'ai fait un
bon sens que j'ai envie de voyager il se
trouve qu'il est parti dans un pays du
maghreb d'accord et qu'il a chopé le
vide à cauville grave là bas maintenant
il est dans saderat parce qu'ils sont en
train de faire une enquête à savoir où
est ce qui s'est fait vacciner ils sont
en train de remonter la piste donc
surtout les enfants ceux qui ont 20 ans
soyez patients inscrivez-vous il est
important de demander aux médecins à vos
médecins à des chercheurs de se dire
aujourd'hui à la possibilité de faire
une vie tranquille qu'on serre la main
mais ne rentrait pas dans un marché
parallèle ça va vous coûter peut-être la
vie à défaut peut-être un petit covin
mais ceux qui vont entrer dans un
coffre-fort je vous assure les effets
sont terribles même encore aujourd'hui
je suis pas guéri c'est vrai je vaux je
suis pas gay c'est pour eux on arrive à
bfmtv je suis désolé oui c'est
malheureux et franchement je suis désolé
si le temps d'hospitalisation allemand
et je suis désolé de tous les gens qui
se sont fait hospitaliser mais il faut
arrêter de faire la guerre des chiffres
c'est ma la voiture la population à
l'égard du terrain ce coach des bleus
oui ou des gens qui meurent du
site une percée vers
toi ce que tu fais ça tu as fait comme
du trading avec des gens de télé réalité
c'est à dire tu as fait du copier coller
lis moi tu ne connais rien du terrain ce
que j'ai vu tous leurs médecins avaient
vécu
trois temps ecoute-moi incroyable écrit
malades et non pas
[Applaudissements]
de la peur
s'est passé fournir moon a le droit je
pense que c'est plus un problème
personnel vis-à-vis de moi plutôt que
vient pas du tout ce qu'on a c'est ce
que mon corps te connais juste deux
minutes
surtout y avait écrit citoyens engagés
vrai ou faux enlèvement engagé et reste
juste citoyen s'il te plaît non j'ai
continué de me suis engagé français ne
s'inquiète pas devait aller jusqu'à
l'arrivée